first of all thank you so much for
sitting down and talking about the film
it looks fantastic the thing we saw some
footage last night and the one thing
that I learned was this amazing tracking
shot that you guys did took like eight
months to plan 27 takes and it's
jaw-dropping to see can you sort of talk
about filming that sequence and how Drew
pitched you on it saying this is what
I'm thinking yeah well I don't like it
seems like there like a magic trick
you're pulling off something with a
bunch of magicians that have to work all
in concert you know and so I don't know
how many takes we what 27 30 takes
something like that to get just all the
timing just right and it's kind of fun
you know I remember when drew said that
tomato
oh cool bad this is like you know it's a
dance step we all have to learn you know
yeah when we were rehearsing in November
and we had a little model of the set and
we would all stand around this little
model and we all have these tiny little
figurines and would be like the true
would be moving everyone around and then
he would be the camera and we all kind
of looked at it from this giant bird's
eye view and then once we're in it it
was like getting it perfect and
rehearsing it to get it perfect and the
timing was so important it was like you
know being in a play and and then once
you did get it perfect it would feel so
good and then sometimes you'd feel like
it was gonna be perfect or you did it
perfect and then something got [ __ ] up
and it would be trash and you believe it
I'm Joel and it's fun
mostly it's really what she's starting
to say something got [ __ ] up okay no
it's fun it's a it's it's yeah it's it's
a strange you you you realize you know
the degree of difficulty is so off the
chart when you try to do something like
that that's that long because if one
thing goes sideways it you have to go
back to beginning and Reese late and
reset and redo and put everything back
to where it was and that's the whole
thing in and of itself so it is it's
like it's like conducting
in Orchestra or something you you have
all of these moving parts that have to
work in concert in such a specific way
and then when you see it it it it kind
of moves you in a very specific way that
just cutting into coverage or chopping
it up into 50 pieces wouldn't because at
certain point you realize on shots like
that whether it's in Goodfellas or
beginning a baby driver or whatever
you're like oh my god this is still
going on they haven't cut out of this
yet and it's in and it makes you kind of
sit up and go okay what's happening next
yeah completely
I think also the for me I notice it but
I think the average moviegoer won't
notice it's such a long take but they'll
feel the sense of anxiety because
they're so used to having quick cuts you
know that's so true when you cut it's
like a subliminal blink you know it
takes you out of the thing you don't
even notice it but it takes you out when
you have that consistent all one
completely my other question for the
three of you I would imagine you all get
offered many projects what was it about
this script that said oh my god I have
to do it me it was a combination of I
came to be very late in fact I'd
probably just talk to you at Sundance
when this came to came to me and they
said you have like 24 hours to read it
and if you like it you have to got a
plane in 48 hours and that was from a
Tuesday to a Friday and then we shot the
next Monday so the turnaround for me was
very fast but unlike most times I get
offers like that this one I've
immediately said yes to because it was a
no-brainer given the cast and given
Drew's record I mean I knew Drew
personally but I and I loved his work so
I was like yeah this is a great one
let's go let's go do this for me it's
kind of movie I wanted to see you know
there's the kind of movies I'd like to
see where I'm on the edge of my seat do
the the filmmakers are ahead of you you
know you think you've got to figure it
out you know and that's what you're
reading the script to this hiking yeah
you read if you pay then I turn a bag I
said wait what happened oh my gosh I'm
what's good what's this and it just
grows in I all of that as well but I
I find that with a character like this I
was so drawn to her because she's so
she's different from anyone I've ever
played she's really broken but fierce
and hardened and not vulnerable it
seemed and then I also found that when
I'm always curious why a director would
think of me for a part I wonder what
they see that I don't see or that I
don't know yet and then you discover or
I discover other things that I'm capable
of and find different parts of the well
and so it's always kind of interesting
that like why why things come to me that
way I'm gonna leave it there and say
there's a reason it's called talented
and I will say it looks fantastic thank
you so much for your time
you